Theo Parnell is a first wave division
agent who has joined forces with Erin
kena backed by the Rikers and impressive
skills in engineering technology in
hacking he brings a number of valuable
assets to kinas mission for this reason
he has a target on his head and the
division of pulling everything out to
put a stop to his involvement in the
chaos that is spreading around the lower
Manhattan
[Music]
you
théo panel showed academic excellence
from an early age unfortunately this
coupled with a strong mistrust of
authority led to a number of
altercations with his teachers and
eventually much larger legal
complications while stills growing up
allegations regarding your son feel I
have nothing further to add as I stated
in my press release these allegations
are completely unfounded
professor Spencer shared his car's data
logs with us this morning which suggests
that the software indeed was tampered
with it corroborates a story which has
nothing to do with my son now excuse me
four months ago your son posted hacking
tutorials online several of which
featured similar car systems being
cracked videos that have since been
removed look I know my son he's a smart
clever boy he likes to pick things apart
to see how they work but he's a
respectful have you seen the video Theo
posted of the accident thank you as the
son of a u.s. senator his father was
able to use his political position to
keep his son out of trouble and more
importantly kips exploits off record
this certainly wasn't without damage to
his own public image though and he was
harshly criticized by others within his
political circle of the course of time
Parnell found his feet curb his
escapades and became an AV remotely
piloted aircraft or RPA pilot as well as
an exceptional mechanical engineer
eventually Parnell was recruited by the
strategic homeland division for his
technical expertise and his highly
innovative approach to problem-solving
during a psychological evaluation it was
noted that he showed extensive
analytical thinking however his weakness
or flaw is that he's incredibly cautious
and trusting higher authority and it was
noticed that this may cause some
conflict in the future
in regards to the division it was
activated as a first wave division agent
to assist the JTF and maintaining
control of the quarantine zone in
Manhattan not long after the operation
failed in the JTF pulled out Parnell's
father passed away under suspicious
circumstances it was around this time
that paranoia sidon he became highly
suspicious of the government and their
objectives I still can't pin anything
directly to Kensington she was out of DC
when it happened and I don't have any
records of meetings or calls with anyone
who could carry out a hit she's smart
probably knew I would look at her first
I need to find another angle even if
they use burner phones that have
staffers scrubbing their data there's no
way they can completely cover their
tracks eventually they'll expose
themselves and they'll be ready
I know Kensington had my dad killed to
protect Waller I know why I know how I
just can't prove it yet later on while
patrolling lower Manhattan Parnell ran
into a nearly rogue agent by the name of
Erin kina and promptly drew his gun and
locked it onto keener that's sir or
equals I'm not sure anymore they're
saying crimes JTF people Walter seemed
to die or Isaac whoa are you saying
compromised I know you feel you know our
tech can be exploited I'm just asking
do I seem rogue to you or is the problem
somewhere higher up
unsurprisingly an in classic kena style
he smoothly talked Parnell around he fit
into his already suspicious nature and
in his mind kina confirmed to him that
the system the government and the
division was without a doubt corrupt to
the core kina wholeheartedly encouraged
Parnell to look into the allegations
seek the whole story and go beyond the
curve and of course who would be more
than happy to lend out his own contacts
to assist in finding the truth through
these interactions kina was able to
convince Parnell to join him as he was
well aware of what he was capable of and
Keenan knew his skills as a tick
specialist with further benefit him and
his future plans and regards to the
government a new virus and his very own
rogue Network
you figure out what happens your dad no
Isaac has access to every database known
to the US government I'm still getting
stonewalled Isaac's got restrictions
clearance levels that you can't access
there's still plenty of the powers that
be don't want you to know like what
really happened to the first wave yeah
everything's a rumor but we've got
cameras and Mike's everywhere it
shouldn't be this hard to find out the
truth it's only hard when they want it
to be hard so it's true
they left you to die cut their losses
because we're expendable that's the fine
print on the contract we are the last
line of defense when the [ __ ] hits the
fan but really they're just using us to
shield them from the [ __ ] I wish I knew
who they are only reason to spot just
look for who's still clean who still has
resources that they shouldn't have you
think the same people behind my dad's
death are responsible for the first wave
I wouldn't be surprised everyone has
secrets feel and the kind of people who
can keep what happens your debts you
could have friends in high places but if
you really want to know what happened I
can help you I got friends in higher
places
how's that guy you get any new leads for
my Intel you were right there's so much
[ __ ] to uncover did you know that Mendez
didn't commit suicide
oh yeah that's clearly a hit do you
think the same people are responsible
for my dad it's possible your dad and
Alice never really saw eye-to-eye it
wasn't the kind of man you could easily
control or manipulate unlike Alice I
didn't think Ellis had that much power
well he's president now he's always been
ambitious what surprised me if he felt
threatened by your dad worried about him
taking a speaker in the next election
cycle if the majority turned yeah that
makes sense
feel if you're not too busy I could use
your help with something
sure what do you need do you think you'd
be able to hack and reprogram an
encrypted guidance system well I can try
you know I love a challenge KYNA
continued to feat Parnell suspicions he
provided him a number of answers and
gave him the means to find Intel that
would have otherwise been hidden to him
because of these resources and they like
minded thinking kina was able to
persuade Parnell to join his side he
eventually disavowed the division began
working for kina and together they
started acting out on kinas plants to
eliminate the division the government
and those calling the shots agent this
is an emergency alert the division is
compromised you have been led to believe
that you serve a noble cause that you
are empowered to do whatever it takes to
save what remains but you don't know the
whole story you don't know who's pulling
the strings and giving the orders the
truth is that you were all unknowingly
serving a shadowy group of profit ears a
group that doesn't want to restore
democracy and freedom create a fascist
plutocracy that only benefits themselves
the division is nothing but a tool to
serve their agenda the division does not
serve the state it does not serve the
people look at the data don't take my
word for it look for yourselves you'll
see I'm telling the truth
varnel is now working for kena almost
immediately is given the job of hacking
into and reprogramming an encrypted
guidance system Parnell managed to
access the code using Isaac began
building a control interface however
there were issues with remote access
most cell towers were out of commission
so they'd have to use satellites and
this would require a command center to
maintain these systems Akina provided
him with the technology resources and an
abandoned containment center where he
could comfortably complete his tasks
there was a lot of work to be done and
it would take resources and most
importantly time and Keena wasn't going
to take any chances with outside
interference from the division so he
requested that dragged off sent over
some manpower in the form of wreckers to
look after the facilities and above all
protect Parnell one of these men
included a racket by the name of Judge
Drago sent you yeah
nice to meet you I'm CEO judge so
where's the executioner
Drago said you needed protection I don't
need protection okay look I know you
don't want us here stomping all over
your precious whatever the [ __ ] this
[ __ ] is don't worry about it but here's
the deal that red ring puts a target on
your back and drag off doesn't want
anyone to kill you prematurely huh
that's very thoughtful of them so we'll
stick around until drag off tells us to
leave honestly I don't give a [ __ ] one
way or the other
I'm just hoping some division [ __ ]
will try to kill you so I can get
another trophy alright well that's
that's cool hey I'm just gonna pump
speed you know I'll be upstairs
KYNA ordered panel along with fellow
rogue agents vivian connelly james
dragged off an havea kojiki to assault
the JTF base of operations and lower
manhattan city hall they attacked the JT
of forces on site and set up kinas newly
developed virus printing devices the
division agents arrived from Washington
DC and investigated the attack while
there they found evidence pointing
directly to Theo Parnell along with his
fellow rogue agent co-conspirators which
proved they were the ones behind the
attacks after further investigation it
was determined that they were in fact
working with kina over the course of
time Parnell was tracked down and found
to be residing in the Civic Center
district and through Intel gathered by
the peacekeepers is found to be hiding
out in the abandoned containment center
the division quickly followed him into
the center but were ambushed by Rikers
upon entry after swiftly taking the
Rutgers down they were then attacked by
a number of Parnell's drones while
making their way through the compound
eventually they reached the courthouse
and were greeted by another group of
ruckus this time lead by a heavy court
judge unsurprisingly although at least
of a man here was no match for the
division it was fair to say by now panel
was running scared trapped and chased to
the far end of the compound and cornered
like a rat in a dead-end hard against
the dark stone walls
he contacted two kina and begged him to
be extracted but Kenya simply told him
to handle his own miss Parnell was on
his own
forced to engage the division he
utilized his Holograms and hacked the
ducts and turrets and a futile attempt
to hold them back but the division
agents were too strong
they managed to push through his drones
turrets and the remaining ruckus and
eventually took him down after defeating
Parnell they commandeered his watch and
handed over to fail ow she would use it
to assist in locating Aaron kena
Aaron kena was able to manipulate Theo
Pannell into doing his bidding this
isn't to say the Parnell wasn't already
on his way
but kena certainly played on his
personality and push them towards team
Road far sooner than he would have on
his own from the information I was going
through I really couldn't find anything
to clear but given Parnell's expertise
I'd say it was quite heavily involved in
the creation and setting up with the
road network but it's tough to tell
exactly how long these two are working
together but what do you think I'm still
missing a handful of collectibles and
Ward's of New York perhaps there is
something in there that talks about it
or maybe we'll find out with the
upcoming seasons thank you very much to
everyone for the support over the last
couple of months who have had some
massive growth especially a big thank
you to those of you who have become
members I'm pretty sure there are
options for member-only chats etc so if
you have anything you want to suggest or
ask go ahead and try those out otherwise
I'll probably be spending a little less
time in the general comments my wife has
told me to stop feeding the trolls so if
you're wanting to get out of me jump
into my Twitter or disgorge or you know
you could click their joint button
anyway thanks again for watching and
I'll catch you the next one Cheers
[Music]